[Music]
Works hey everyone uh I'm Jed Schmid I'm
going to be your host for today I'm just
going to give you a quick little intro
uh and and then if I'm just going to
basically introduce the speakers as they
come out uh if you have any questions
you can feel free to come up to me or
anyone else on the team uh so Jed Schmid
so you're probably thinking this guy has
really excellent German um but uh no I'm
actually I'm from New York I don't
actually speak German uh so I didn't
know what to do the intro and should I
like do it in English but then that's
kind of douchy cuz like here's this
American coming and speaking English so
I didn't want to do it in English so
here's what I'm going to try I'm going
to try giving you the intro to today's
conference entirely in CSS uh so this is
the challenge I'm a little bit nervous
about it um I studied all of the HTML 5
element names I studied all of the css3
property names and so here we go intro.
CSS or if you're German intro
csz pre 96 uh anyway okay cool so first
of all hi um hi you
all uh hi
everybody um here is your intro I'm
basically just want to give you a
background uh about CSS comp I'm sorry
that is uh that's not turn the numbers
but then the and oh
and okay cool it's a nice orange uh
so yeah CSS comp I think you'll love
it it hurts me too don't worry um but
before we start uh I'm just going to
some filler content here um and you
might find it a little bit off color um
you might find it uh the jokes are
somewhat
opaque uh maybe some of the jokes are a
little bit of a stretch uh speaking of
the jokes I'm just going to list them up
um you know it's trying to lighten the
mood uh some of them might make you a
little bit embarrassed you know make
your face red or make you blush better
known as FFF F5 uh but I am a bottomless
Trove of bad CSS jokes uh so I don't
think I'll have any trouble there
they're not all funny but like every
10th joke will float just right and
we'll be comic gold so uh just bear with
me if if it seems slow um gold also
obviously ffd700 um so I just want to
give you a background of the area uh
here we are in Berlin uh it's a
conference about style in a city that
has style Berlin has so much style its
Styles have style
um and that just keeps repeating forever
um yeah it's like just walking out on
the street just seeing people on the
street uh man it is so stylish uh even
here at burgain people waiting in line
have style you would say they have in
line
style and because it's Germany the line
height is about two two what it usually
is where I'm where I'm from um but you
don't want to use inline Styles is right
that's bad you want to use you want to
use class uh and you know this is City
obviously there a lot of history has a
lot of class uh I haven't seen this much
class it's almost too much class like
Brin is almost too classy I haven't seen
this much excessive class since I last
used
modernizer uh about the area also we are
right next to the Berlin Wall uh if you
no uh it's about uh 2 million pixels to
your left
um uh it is this solid border that used
to divide
Germany until 1989 when it
collapsed so uh it's uh it's actually
kind of hard to find you actually can't
find the Berlin wall with uh CSS you're
going to need to use JavaScript using
jQuery I'm sure you guys all know how to
do this uh jqu you just put in selector
so uh you just find an area that has
sof and and uh you can find the Berlin
Wall it's a he's wearing a jacket you
you'll see it uh it shouldn't be too
hard to find um so about this address
where we are right now we are on invalid
stasa uh and again I don't know German
I'm pretty sure that invalid stasa in
English would just be a street address
that is
disabled it's my guess it's a read I
have um and about this particular
section of this area um it's V Elizabeth
uh it is background about the position
of this place it is right in the center
of Berlin uh you can see these uh
beautiful uh White Walls the background
here is white uh better known as FFF
ffff but it's actually the building's a
little bit old so it's faded a little
bit it's actually more like a f AE bd7
better know was antique
white uh apparently fading is Perfectly
Natural uh this in a white space uh
perfectly normal that that happens so
don't worry about it um so this is
actually like a parish uh you can't
really tell it's not on display but this
is actually uh you know a religious
institution uh so it's not only on
display but if you were here like maybe
50 years ago it would be more of a
display nun kind of thing um anyway uh
so let's talk about this conference it
is an import from the states uh CSS com
started uh we're going to hear more
about that later from Nicole um let's
talk about cssc actually hold on let me
get a little bit more specific let's
talk about cssc EU um it's the first of
its type it's I think as far as I the
only of its type it is for the
organizers is their first conference and
I'm sure you know what that means it is
nth child index one so of all the
children it's like the index is one or
as some of you would say the index is
one um so yeah see come you it's uh it's
it's not for profit right so there's no
margin they don't make any margin on
this uh hopefully when they're done
there will be nothing
left I assume uh what I hope is not the
case that they actually have extra money
and they just hide it so let's hope that
that is is not happening uh let's talk
about the list of the speakers we have
excellent speakers they are in the top
1% of their field uh they are the
backgrounds are really really badass uh
you would also say absolutely badass um
so uh during while you're listening to
the speakers if you are unable to focus
uh next we have a selection of
delicious black
coffee but I've heard unfortunately we
have zero decaf uh which you know if
you're not a caffeine person is bad bad
but let me give you some background on
that apparently uh the organizers asked
them to do decaf uh and uh all they said
was uh
99999 and then just no decaf so um I
realized that's a lot of background
jokes in a row so I'm just going to turn
off repeat on the background jokes don't
worry about that it's the last one um uh
also mentioned the toilet um if you need
directions ask me later um
and once you so if you have to drink a l
coffee and you have to pee after you
visit the toilet and you're empty of
pee everything will be fixed everything
will be all right so uh definitely give
that a visit um I want to talk we have
this policy they mentioned uh it's the
anti-jerk policy so I just want to give
you in the in the context of CSS what
that entails so um take this pretty
seriously uh don't disable user
selection on all elements uh that's kind
of douchy uh don't every seven images
don't rotate them 180 degre like that's
pretty douchy
um don't fade all the paragraphs to zero
like I can't see them after 500 seconds
like don't do that that that would be a
jerky thing to do and finally uh don't
uh blink all of your H1s all right so
just a guy just don't do that stuff that
would be that would that would
definitely fall under the jerk policy uh
one more point I want to make uh it's uh
I'm sorry one point I guess it would be
uh pretty important Point uh I want to
talk about uh if you guys take photos or
of anything totally totally cool uh but
would love if you guys could share them
uh you can just you can display them
online if you want to or you could you
know put them around your block or
both
um but it would be a shame if after
cssc we were left with zero picks so
just make sure you share them that's all
I ask uh and that's about it uh and so
without further Ado uh I would like to
bring
up our first keynote or our keynote our
first Speaker uh needs very little
introduction so she will get none uh
ladies and gentlemen stubborn Nicole
[Applause]
Sullivan